[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
comic-book entertainment I am your host
today Walter Bonet dziak
and we have two special guests on the
show but let me tell you what we're
talking about we're talking about the
worst dirt worst and we have got some
bad ones guys the worst of Marvel's
comic book villains there are a few
really bad ones that we're gonna discuss
first but before we go into that or
we're gonna remind you to like the
Facebook page facebook.com slash Ross
economics show we have new videos that
go up in there every single Thursday and
sometimes more than once a week so make
sure you check out that Facebook page
this past week Heather and Lucas talked
about we tasted a nerdy beer guitar yes
by revolution brewing here in Chicago
and it was awesome that's great
check it out yes awesome comic Show
check it out for that exclusive content
and Heather how you doing today I'm
doing fine you know just chillin
Saturday yes y'all know we filmed these
on Saturday sorry about the illusion I
mean it's not like this isn't live right
now moment Jim what's going on Jim chaos
yeah not too much things were good back
on the show back on the show yeah how's
it feel good I don't need to fit in and
I just fit in yeah all right we're gonna
start with Heather ladies first here who
is your worst
Marvel Comics villain ever okay so I
think one of the worst Marvel comic
villains ever is Matador Matador Matador
yes he mostly fights daredevil and first
popped down to the scene in 1964 and one
of the best things I think about him in
the worst way of course is that he has
no superpowers whatsoever none he is
just literally a matador he like
apparently is that he's a good sword
fighter and like he's very advocate fire
oh super powers he actually does the
schtick where he like just waves the
red-crab the whole
about it is that he fights daredevil
waves this red glove in front of
daredevil and doodles I see right
through your ploy you're supposed to run
after this because it's red the same
color as your suit and a lot of the
times he comes back a couple of times
and a lot of the times he's taken out by
like a single punch
joke I mean he's he's in the cash what
is it called emissary of evil I think
it's like Matador leapfrog who is also
terrible man's in there too like it's
not it's not great dear it has some
these guys like near the form of the
loops because they're like alright we're
doing terrible out there we have ideas
we have no superpowers here we go ya
know his origin story is even ridiculous
in that man well that's who was real
identity is a man he's like the greatest
bullfighter in all of Spain he is too
cruel to the animals so let that one
sink
bullfighter bullfighter oh there's like
no you're worse right I mean we all stab
bulls enjoy his matches people like with
rioters they right in the streets
because he's just so cool to these bulls
and that makes him turn on humanity Wow
it's it's pretty great and then for some
random reason so he was mostly like I
said 1964 was when he first appeared on
the scene and then for some reason
randomly in daredevil volume 2 issue 89
in 2006 he shows up again but it's not
the same guy it's not men well it's like
some random guy named
not how I feel right yeah
he doesn't have the same backstory at
all he's hired by someone to like foil
Daredevils plans and then like never
shows up again yes
[Music]
yet he was just hired by Vanessa Fisk
yeah and one of his first appearances he
Rob's an armored truck by like yeah and
then tosses the wrench onto the
windshield of the armored car and
they're like oh god we didn't plan for
this
let's get him to show up again a
different guy
do you have someone worse than Bobby
he's necessarily worse but he's in the
same vein he's well he's he's in the
league right right
my guy is still man okay so still man
also a daredevil really he got all the
winners I guess it was like he's blind
you know they're like well he's not
going to judge us how stupid
so still man is basically executive
sounds yes he's a suit with telescopic
leagues which allow him to propel them
in the air and walk over things okay
terribly successful to just being pushed
over and over well yeah it wasn't it
initially it was four legs that were on
the top floor I don't want to take the
other window give me all your money yeah
then they just push him over there is
kind of like an iconic I feel like it I
kind of cover up daredevil where do you
like it's like a warm zai view if you
see like stilt man and like Daredevils
like swinging past his legs kind of you
know and he was he was co-created by
Stanley Manley in Hollywood I think
where the original creators so he you
know it's like we know well is drying up
you got to come up with ideas do you
know 65 at 65 man 60s I mean because I
guess that's the Silver Age right so
they're throwing out a ton of weird
stuff then some of it stuck spider-man
sure I could stick to walls and the
amazing spider-man wasn't even really
even like gonna be a fly or something
like fly man yeah he's a soft Y crawling
along was like that'd be great if he
could stick to walls
Wow anyway a superhero all right yeah oh
I don't know why I like my Stan Lee
impression is always 90 year old yes to
talk
slow only 40 years old all right well
don't man was around for a while to wait
was he a recurring did he also fight
spider-man occasionally he did for a
while - he was a couple of it was a
couple of different people in the suit
and for a while like Thor apprehend he's
gonna make a nice suit he's got a
mechanized you sure his legs extend he's
basically a prototype for inspector
gasps Wow he had only a female
counterpart as well - really who was a
woman no no that would be the logical
thing right
she was lady stilt man ladies ladies
Deadpool so probably a little bit of a
joke she fought dentists recently I
don't even let's see I can see amazing
spider-man number 611 is what I ever
okay down the road a piece
I don't know yeah I know so uh Deadpool
actually defeated her by doing what as
you would with a stilt person removing a
manhole cover and she that would you
know spider-man I think you do like the
Empire Strikes Back hospitality Mike's
partner man daredevil share a lot of
villains because kingpin is a big
villain for daredevil and it's also a
big big villain for spider-man maybe
because I think they're in New York too
so it seems like they shared the good
and the bad villains I guess yeah yeah I
feel like that was definitely another
fun fact about stilt man though when he
was operated by Turk he was rejected
from kingpins gang you know I came to be
like I'm gonna be an assassin for you
and King Finn was like ah all right well
you still man infinite are pretty bad I
go oh that's bad but this might
okay okay you ready
asbestos not to be confused with
asbestos lady no their forties they're
there it's completely separate villains
they both want the Fantastic Four though
I think or at least the Human Torch
anaphoras asbestos man okay so not
lately like you said not to be viewed
with with asbestos lady but this is also
in the 60s in 1963 he was originating in
and also co-created by Stan Lee we need
something that's fire retardant on the
wall yes I want to hear Stanley say
asbestos imagine seeing asbestos Hey
it's gotta be someone yeah what is your
favorite villain we've ever created Stan
well I back in the 60s I came up with
your villain name and he was made of
acid it's not exactly made of asbestos
but he does have a super asbestos suit
remember super asbestos suit that's
important there yeah he's made but he's
basically made to fight the Human Torch
because he is why are retardant whatever
his suit is ridiculous and I was trying
to picture right here but he has like
this ridiculous mask and a net that's a
net the shield is the asbestos net is
super asbestos net which catches things
I guess I guess it's the in case the
Human Torch
I don't know right I guess I guess not
but I mean just when I was looking up
villains for this - it's just like
asbestos man was like asbestos man
sounds like a joke sounds like a family
guy Joker so it does these people we
didn't know until like the 80s I think
that asbestos was dangerous so I guess
this is like a makes sense for that time
very illogical leap because that's your
weird joke now though
ultimately right the funniest thing
about this right this guy by the way his
calves it was a doctor dr. Orson Karloff
so that's great he was a not too smart
doctor but so he he but he only showed
up I think a couple times in the 60s and
maybe even once but he randomly just
shows up and fear itself the Marvel of
Ephram to that 11 just randomly shows up
let me read you this
asbestos manager bill to have developed
cancer due to the toxicity of his super
super super and is now living in an
oxygen test he makes he makes it clear
that he wants to return to his life as a
villain but is persuaded not to by the
Great Lakes Avengers so not even like
the main Avengers team to stop asbestos
man from thinking about going out again
in fact people with his asbestos
contamination and then years later the
Human Torch just mentions that he died
exactly yeah no he's dead really yeah so
what's this lady was dead in the 90s but
I mean when you think of pathetic
villains this is pretty pathetic yeah
asbestos man asbestos super suit and
then he dies this later of cancer right
I'm his own suit from his own suit
that's pretty freaking twist of Saturday
morning special yeah yeah well kids let
me tell you about this thing asbestos
its carcinogenic yeah might be slow but
you'll be dead exactly suppose there are
worse Marvel comic book villains those
are pretty bad those are pretty bad can
we see I would love to see some kind of
like animated version of these
characters I still man I think it'd be
really fun
and or to asbestos man would just be sad
but I would the Mantid or something
ridiculous yeah I put them in there
that'd be fun let's give these guys well
like another one that's kind of rethink
it was like whirlwind one of the
cartoons I forgot about that
yeah he's like it's funny and it's like
here's a Sunni again just as a suit that
allows them I think he's a normal guy
who just allows them to yeah basically
it tells me him devil all the place so
of course not in one of the Avengers
cartoons I think oh there you go wasn't
a cartoon right well let's talk about
picks of the week comic book picks of
the week which are all centered around
these guys Jim where did you guys your
guy appearing weird still I think was
originally daredevil number eight okay
that was 1965 right so we'll throw that
that picture up there there you go
Heather weirded daredevil number five
1964 we'll check that out go I'm sure
it's outlined some oh yeah and in the
dude then the recent one was 2006 so oh
yeah it was
daredevil volume 2 number 89 okay so
check out that one too for the the
return exactly um so yeah I suppose this
man that's a real thing asbestos man
strange tales number 111 from August
1963 that might be online somewhere go
check that out
and also if you want to see him please
come this big comeback in fear itself
which was a big Marvel crossover from
2011 so check out that if you want to
see the return of asbestos man I haven't
actually read fear itself but I heard
it's pretty good so go check that one
out for yourself well and I was saying
earlier to Marvel has compiled a lot of
their gold and silver Age comics into
these essential omnibus right so those
are always really interesting to check
out I used to have a whole bunch of
copies in my classroom the kids would
always take them take a look they're
just called like essential Iron Man or
essential right yes you know yeah
right there pretty cool right so what is
uh what's your guy's least favorite or I
don't know the worst Marvel villain do
you think these guys are the worst who's
the worst among us yeah who did
everything is the word yeah
I mean it's because he's so pathetic
that's the thing he's so pathetic yeah
but if you have someone worse let us
know in the comments below because I
would love to hear worse than asbestos
man or still man on the mound or please
almost forgot you're on Facebook right
yeah Facebook ed James Jim J res right
and yeah okay check that out
Heather you can find me on Twitter at
Heather ruse or Instagram a teachers
okay cool and I am on Twitter as usual
and awesome underscore Walter getting a
lot of feedback on those cartoon top
fives I've been doing so yeah I keep
suggesting stuff you guys want to see on
there and for awesome comics as well and
make sure to like the Facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome comic show as
I said before every Thursday new videos
and sometimes more than once a week so
exclusive contact to our Facebook page
so until next time these guys are great
they're not the worst the opposite of
the worst we need you so until next week
guys we'll see you on the next page
[Music]
[Applause]